welcome to this video playing my old
nemesis gasps mr. play on time in every
position okay if I go for the Kings
Indian he will play the exchange
variation as you probably would have
guessed um Jim don't do something else
maybe i can i can get get another type
of position here I just want to get get
out of theoretical theoretical stuff
yeah it's not the greatest line in the
world but I don't want to have the
exchange variation on the board against
the sky it will play this for 120 moves
and never ever consider draw I know I
know what I'm talking about okay um I
just play for be 5 p.m. yeah
you know what can play Bishop age 60 m
if he wants on try to keep more pieces
on the body my main idea was to to not
get get a dry head game quickly okay I
probably need to have returned I just
want to have a full position on the body
even if it's not so great ok trying to
prepare be five but this will be will be
difficult can I go e six young maybe six
I have the default square if it takes
light X taking us as bad simply and term
maybe i can i can transpose to some sort
of now if he takes with the rook
nighties knight c6 should be ok ok it
doesn't um yeah let's let's let's close
this term then now try to play on the
e-file with the Queen side completely
paralyzed I don't think this is so
brilliant for why Trillium
okay I wonder about Bishop d4 here is
this an idea my sis to him somehow some
are stupid maybe it's probably not I am
I better not I better not it's not
really leading to much okay maybe try to
double on the e farm it's really a moot
point he will probably not do anything
here just stay put
okay rookie 70 just retreat you simply
didn't happen nothing happens here um
okay rookie seven maybe then Bishop g5 I
don't know yeah I can I can I can play
that no Bishop f6 again or Knight f6 and
tending rookie aid
I can go to pho no check
I came some if I'm like I should must be
a bit cautious I shouldn't allow
anything like Bishop to the ATM this
will pick up pick up the pawn cm
check
yeah white can and of course claim form
for some slight advantage it's nothing
too serious with the queenside frozen
but term of course he will play rook
against Luke myself he was I certainly
play that one I would play this of
course as well for win because it is a
bit better for widen yeah I now f5 I
probably must do that check yeah this is
now it's really dry but this doesn't
mean anything here let's see the Knight
to f5 via this would completely kill it
but do i do I get it do I get it down
what this exactly what can he try to try
the night the grain culture the bishop
to h3 at some point I don't know
basically white can do nothing but
yeah bringing it to h3 and some way now
maybe even shuffle it over here but ok
then you can play a 5 and young yeah
it's not so easy this is not the time to
lay I mean white is better it's probably
something that black should draw in a
long time control game but it's it's
tricky to do yes there's a five idea
yeah I wasn't sure why he played it
before why I didn't play it before it
should be five for us probably probably
not possible
hmm it's probably really what check hmm
now kid with the time here's some is
winning anyway I'm not sure that this
was really laughing for a fence on time
this um I mean I didn't understand that
all why he wasn't just taking on e5 this
win so very easily check what what else
do you want here this this is just all
just winning forward but ok I there
there are some fortress ideas he went
here night-night be eight drawers I can
go to the sudden it's very easy to
actually check no and that's that's
relatively easier yeah but this was
still a bit a bit annoying this is all
end game it's it's a well known type of
endgame from the Arabic but here i have
the queenside closed which I thought
should should help a bit in defence but
it's not it's not easy at all yeah you
can you can just stay put here it's not
not much that I can do and it's also me
I am maybe a timing issue a five assists
coming but maybe maybe I shouldn't go
where five is immediately
check Joe yeah there is no clear way to
draw that I mean if I have unlimited
time I'm md i'm getting this in this is
what I tried and that's really a draw
but it's long it's a long long journey
and it's not it's not going to happen
you can always combine this f5 and the
bishop to d8 ideas I'm not sure if with
perfect play black and draw this ok this
wasn't a great idea I wanted to get this
night to g7 um but it's some are
actually maybe i can i can try this this
this way like this here here here this I
could try oh yeah but it's always it's
always something I always and not
something for white you know it's some
not a very comfortable position type
anyway i thought i should draw Haley but
I wonder no g5 is also not great
I'm just wondering if I can't put a perm
a tougher defense actually I maybe this
is better maybe it's ugly but maybe it's
better it has some it has some
fortress-like qualities if you imagine
my king to only seven and the night on
g7 how to see how does he make any
headway out here here King here night
here Herbert maybe I maybe get zoom
swamped at some point
this could be a draw I mean not not nice
it's not like you're opening the
champagne bottles here but it's maybe
maybe at all maybe not very comfortable
all right thanks for watching